in this segment we will talk about sets
I am pretty sure that most of what we
are you will say is material that you
have seen before
nevertheless it is useful to do a review
of some of the concepts the definitions
and also of the notation that we will be
using so what is a set a set is just a
collection of distinct elements so we
have some elements and we put them
together and this collection we call it
the set s more formally how do we
specify a set we could specify it set by
listing its elements and putting them
inside braces so this is a set that
consists of our elements the letters a b
c d another set could be the set of all
real numbers
notice a distinction here the first set
is a finite set it has a finite number
of elements whereas the second set is
infinite and in general sets are of
these two kinds either their finite or
their infinite a piece of notation now
we use this notation to indicate that a
certain object X is an element of a set
s we read that as X belongs to s if X is
not an element of s then we use this
notation to indicate it and we read it
as X does not belong to s now one way of
specifying sets is as follows we start
with a bigger set for example the set of
real numbers and we consider all those
X's that belong to that big set that
have a certain property for example that
the cosine of this number is let's say
bigger than 1/2 this is a way of
specifying a set we start with a big set
but we then restrict to those elements
of that set that satisfy a particular
property one set of particular interest
is the following sometimes in some
context we want to fix
a collection of all possible objects
that we might ever want to consider and
that collection will be a set we denote
it usually by Omega and we call it the
universal set
so having fixed a universal set we will
only consider smaller sets that lie
inside that big Universal set and once
we have a universal set we can talk
about the collection of all objects or
elements that belong to our Universal
set but do not belong to the set s so
that would be everything outside the set
s everything outside the set s we denote
it this way and we call it the
complement of the set s and it is
defined formally as follows an element
belongs to the complement of s if X is
an element of our universal set and also
X does not belong to s notice that if we
take the complement of the complement
that is anything that does not belong to
the green set we get back the red set so
what this is saying is that the
complement of the complement of a set is
the set itself another set of particular
interest is the so-called empty set the
empty set is a set that contains no
elements in particular if we take the
complement of the universal set
well since the universal set contains
everything there is nothing in its
complement so its complement is going to
be the empty set finally one more piece
of notation suppose that we have two
sets and one set is bigger than the
other so s is the small set here and T
is the bigger set
we denote this relation by writing this
expression which we read as follows
s is a subset of the set T and what that
means is that if X is an element of s
then such an X must be also an element
of T note that when s is a subset of T
there is also the possibility that s is
equal to T one word of caution here the
notation that we are using here is the
same as what in some textbooks is
written this way that is s is a subset
of T but can also be equal to T we do
not use this notation but that's how we
understand it that is we allow for the
possibility that the subset is equal to
the larger set now when we have two sets
we can talk about their Union and their
intersection let's say that this is set
s and this is set T the union of the two
sets consists of all elements that
belong to one set or the other or in
both the union is denoted this way and
the formal definition is that some
element belongs to the Union if and only
if this element belongs to one of the
sets or it belongs to the other one of
the sets we can also form the
intersection of two sets which we denote
this way and which stands for the
collection of elements that belong to
both of the sets so formally an element
belongs to the intersection of two sets
if and only if that element belongs to
both of them
so X must be an element of s and it must
also be an element of T by the way we
can also define unions and intersections
of more than two sets even of infinitely
many sets so suppose that we have an
infinite collection of sets let's denote
them by SN so n ranges over let's say
all the positive integers so pictorially
you might think of having one set
another set third set the fourth set and
so on and we have an infinite collection
of such sets given this infinite
collection we can still define their
Union to be the set of all elements that
belong to one of those sets s and that
we started with that is an element is
going to belong to that Union if and
only if this element belongs to some of
the sets that we started with we can
also define the intersection of an
infinite collection of sets we say that
an element X belongs to the intersection
of all these sets if and only if X
belongs to s n for all n so if X belongs
to each one of those s ends then we say
that X belongs to their intersection set
operations satisfy certain basic
properties one of these we already
discussed this property for example is
pretty clear the union of a set with
another set is the same as the Union if
you'd consider the two sets in different
orders if you take the union of three
sets you can do it by forming first the
union of these two sets and then the
union with this one or do it in any
alternative order both expressions are
equal because of this we do not really
need the parentheses and we often write
just this expression here which is the
same as this one
and the same would be true for
intersections that is the intersection
of three sets
is the same no matter how you put
parentheses around the different sets
now if you take a union of a set with
the universal set you cannot get
anything bigger than the universal set
so you just get the universal set on the
other hand if you take the intersection
of a set with the universal set what is
left is just the set itself perhaps the
more complicated properties out of this
list is this one and this one which are
sort of a distributive property of
intersections and unions and I will let
you convince yourselves that these are
true the way that they you verify them
is by proceeding logically if X is an
element of this then X must be an
element of s and it must also be an
element of either T or u therefore it's
going to be long either to this set it
belongs to s and it also belongs to T or
it's going to be an element of that set
it belongs to s and it belongs to you so
this argument shows that this set here
is a subset of that set anything that
belongs here belongs there then you need
to reverse the argument to convince
yourselves that anything that belongs
here belongs also to the first set and
therefore the two sets are equal here
I'm using the following fact that if s
is a subset of T and T is a subset of s
this implies that the two sets are equal
and then you can use a similar argument
to convince yourselves about this
equality as well so this is it about
basic properties of sets we will be
using some of these properties all of
the time without making any special
comment about them